okay let's uh get started without
further Ado so welcome to lecture number
10 we progressing
fast and where what have we learned so
far just a very quick recapitulation of
where we are so in the last I don't know
five six lectures the focus has been on
bins physics and form neural
networks and we have seen that for many
PDS these are great right especially if
you don't have a lot of training data
this is something that I'm going to
highlight quite a bit today but as we
saw in the last lecture there's several
negatives in in particular the key
negative that we found out was training
can be
expensive training is
difficult and the reason for that is
this uh sort of intrinsic properties of
physics inform losses where the Herm
Mission squared the condition number of
the Herm Mission the conditioning of the
Herm mission squar of the differential
operator really matters so from that
perspective and also if you remember
that in terms of the PDS themselves what
we saw is that they were very good for
certain pdes which are let's say smooth
Solutions not too difficult Solutions
but once you are difficult Solutions
once there are lots of frequencies lots
of scales which is the case in reality
then we are at a in trouble right so in
that sense we do need Alternatives and
especially the Alternatives make a lot
lot of sense when more data is available
and how much of data is more data we are
going to talk about that quite a lot
during the next several lectures so now
let's change perspective and what we're
going to do is for the next several
lectures what we're going to do is to
look at supervised learning supervised
learning is essentially leveraging the
data that is available to us right so we
start now and till the end of the month
at least the month of April that is we
will deal with this perhaps even early
me okay so let's let's get started so
before even sort of going towards uh
data driven Solutions or pdes let me try
to revisit or recapitulate the question
of what does it mean to solve a PD right
so what does it mean to solve APD what
do we do when we solve APD and this is
going to be important uh for what we're
going to discuss so let's try to
understand that through a very simple
example right so this is a very
important PD it's a prototype type of
what are called elliptic PES this is
what is called
elliptic and uh this is modeling various
things so it depends on what your
quantities of Interest are so for
instance the youu here this guy here
this could be the temperature or it
could be the pressure or it could be
some other property let's say that if
the temperature the pressure then
depending on the application that we
have the a here so this is what is
called a coefficient
for instance if you're modeling heat
conduction then this a is precisely the
conductance or the
conductivity is the same if a for or U
is a voltage for instance then this is
electrical conductivity but on the other
hand if it's a pressure of a fluid that
is trapped inside on the under the
ground then this would be the rock
permeability the the sort of material
properties of the medium itself so this
is the the point is that it tells you
something about the material it tells
you something about the domain but the
action is happening and finally F this
is much simpler to understand this is
just a source term right so just imagine
that you have a rod which is of made of
of a material that is not uniform and
then you start heating it then of course
the source is the heating Source the
material is given by the material
properties and U is going to be the
temperature and this is modeled by this
elliptic PD which is called the
diffusion PD or sometimes it's even
called the D C PD particularly in fluid
d
so this is the situation with the PD so
what we can think of is we can think of
the PD itself as a system like any
system it takes an input or inputs and
it processes them into outputs so what
are the
inputs so at least for this particular
PD this is clearly the
coefficient so this is a and it is the
source
term
f it could also be the boundary
conditions the domain and so on but
let's let's keep things simple let's say
that for this particular PD your inputs
are the coefficients and sources and in
particular I could be interested in a
situation for instance if I'm drilling
under the ground that I fix this so let
us keep this fixed so if I fix the
source then essentially the task of the
PD and I forgotten to write what the
outputs are going to be the output is
just the
solution solution which is given by you
here so essenti you can think of the PD
as a system that takes an input in this
particular case the coefficient and the
source but let's say just the
coefficient and it turns out an output
which in this particular case is the
solution of the PD in other words it
takes a coefficient a here as you can
see it has some spatial fluctuations and
then it turns out an output which is
given by the solution of a PD as you can
see the a does not look remotely like
the input here the coefficient does not
look remotely like the output because
what the output tells you is how the
fluid is distributed somehow the
pressure of the fluid is going to be
distributed right so in other words in
this particular case you can sort of say
that solving a PD is T amount to finding
out what is called the solution operator
the solution operator is this object
which exactly does the systemic
transformation it takes a input and it
produces an output so it takes the input
a the coefficient here and it produces
an output which is the solution to the
PD which is given by this
okay so remember that this is the way
you can think of differential equations
that these are transformations that take
inputs to outputs except that there is
something special about this inputs and
outputs unlike a standard function which
takes a finite dimensional input and
provides a finite dimensional output
here the inputs and outputs and this is
this is a these are
functions and these
sorry I don't know
some
reason some reason
it anyway so the these inputs and
outputs both of them the solution itself
clearly is a
function so what do I mean by it so the
input itself is an infinite dimensional
quantity because it's a function it
cannot be described in principle by
finitely many parameters and so is the
output function which is described in
terms of finitely many parameters that's
why the transformation that takes the
input and turns out the output is an
operator because operators are
generalizations of functions which takes
infinite dimensional inputs and turn out
infinite dimensional outputs so this is
a very important Point here that solving
a PD essentially is finding or Computing
or calculating or approximating the
solution operator and this is
intrinsically object that transforms
infinite dimensional quantities into
Infinite dimensional quantities and
you'll see why this is an issue in a
very short time so this is one example
right but is this General enough and the
answer is yes indeed if you take another
PD for instance it's a Time dependent
one I just took one for definiteness but
there's nothing special about it so
these are the compressible oiler
equations of fluid dynamics for instance
aerodynamics the flow of air just
outside this room is going to be
governed by the compressible oiler
equations and as you can see these are
much more complex PDS than this simple
Scala PD right but uh if you're Ed these
quantities have some meaning row here is
the density of the fluid V is the
velocity field so in 2D or 3D it's two
or three components e is the total
energy B is the pressure and then you
have an equation of State uh there is a
equation of state which relates
them and usually for an ideal gas the
total energy is given by P over gamma -
1 + half row v² something like like this
okay so this is a detail that this is a
fairly complex PD now here let's say
that we fixed the there no sources there
is no forcing there's no coefficient
let's say it's a flow of air so there is
nothing to impede the flow and then we
have just um Square domain periodic
bounding conditions just for Simplicity
all these can be additional inputs and
all that we are left with is are the
initial conditions here's an example of
an initial condition a typical initial
condition that for instance happens when
you you look at the clouds uh it's a
Shear so you have the density and I
don't know whether you can see this but
this is a Shear so the velocity goes in
this direction and here it goes in this
direction okay so there's a she and
because of that the flow becomes very
very complicated and at a later time as
you can see this is a very complex flow
so this is the density what I'm showing
here is a density this is a density but
of course every variable changes and you
can see that there are lots of complex
vortices and fingers and so on and so
forth so fairly complex solution but
again the idea is so this is a solution
at later time T let's say this is t
equal to 1 some unit time and some
idealized units that we have so what is
the solution operator in this particular
case what is the transformation that
we're interested in the transformation
now takes the initial condition and it
produces the solution at a lat time or
at any given time right this is a
trajectory any given time could be
encapsulated in these terms but let's
say it's simply the solution at a later
time so again it takes the a here is the
initial condition and U here is the
final the solution at a final time which
is given in terms of the operator of the
PD so again it takes a function clearly
a function it's defined at every single
point similarly the output is also going
to be a function right so in other words
you have an operator which takes a to U
do T the dot here means that it's sort
of given at any any any given point in
space so again it's the same story that
solving the pde is the same as Computing
this transformation that takes a
infinite Dimension function input and
transforms it into a function output
okay so this is what it means and we can
sort of make it abstract so that things
are easier to understand in some sense I
don't have to keep on writing specific
PDS all the time by simply taking a
abstract perspective so now remember
that at the end of the day we have
functions which get mapped onto
functions and this is done by
operators so any questions about that so
this is this is the key setup that we
are in and we will we will deal with
this setup okay so now just for
Simplicity we take a function because
our inputs and outputs are functions so
what we do is that we take a function
space here we take a function space here
and of course uh since we going to take
data we need some data distribution so
this me you can think of it as a data
distribution but the data is function
valued now each time you're going to
pluck uh a point a sample of the data
you'll get an object like this so just
think you you have a library of images a
library of functions and you choose some
at random so that is the thinking of a
data distribution okay and then there is
some abstract pde so the abstract PD is
clearly given here the same as what we
did dealt with with pins no change there
and now the important thing is now I put
both the coefficients as well as the
sources in one bracket and simply say
that there's a solution operator that
Maps X to Y so this here is
G right so this is the abstract setup
that we are going to do and the task
here is also very clear because now for
every PD we have associated with the PD
as solution operator right for instance
which takes the coefficients to the
solution or it takes the initial
conditions to the solution and so on and
so forth and now what we'll be given is
data right so this data that is going to
come to us that's why I mentioned that
there is a measure with respect to it so
what do you do let me choose this so you
choose
AI from this distribution me so remember
that AI is are functions mu is a
distribution on functions so you have to
choose this and then the data that is
given to you is AI and G of AI for
Simplicity plus Some Noise Okay so this
is going to be your
data so given this data so a could be a
large number it could be a small number
it depends on the on the data set that
you have so for instance if you think of
weather and climate data this a this
number a is typically something like
60,000 members okay it will have 60,000
members in in the standard weather data
sets but for some other applications
this could only be five members so there
is a huge disparity in the size of this
data set but it is not in the order of
the sort of Internet scale data that we
have for text and images where there are
billions and billions of data points and
some so that this is this is going to be
a challenge right so given this data the
task is to learn the operator right so
learn G so this is what is called
operator learning
and as I said means there is no other
solution to this because intrinsically
your inputs and outputs are infinite
dimensional so you have to in know to
solve the PD you have to learn the
operator are there any questions on this
because this is a very very important
point no everyone understands this also
on Zoom are there any questions you can
always ask questions on the chat box and
so okay yes yes of course
[Music]
yeah you didn't get this part okay I can
explain it to you no problems so shall I
explain it to this example first so okay
let me take you a very simple example
right so let's say that uh even even
simpler so that hopefully this will be
much clearer and to everyone else let me
give you an example and maybe I don't
want to clutter my writing even more
let me write it on
some okay let's take a very simple
example let us say that my domain is 01
cross 0
t okay doesn't matter if it's 01 cross 0
t means
um Let me let me erase this cuz now I
have to improvise a little so let's say
that it's R the real line cross zero
just for Simplicity my PD is the section
equation several of you have seen this
I'm
sure okay and this rection equation and
this is given by UT plus Au ux equal Z
and I took the whole line because I
didn't want to bother with boundary
conditions okay and now your a here is
so and your initial conditions are U not
of
X okay so these are functions right you
of X is a function so now your solution
operator s of T takes
U to St of U and who can tell me what is
the solution of this PD so given
U what is U of
XT this is just adicction
yes xus 8 perfect so this is just
advection right so this is the solution
of the PD so now as you can see that you
start with any function right so let's
start with a function let's say that is
sign some form of sign after a while
what happens is that you get this
sorry you get this transported so it
becomes something like this things move
right so this is so now what is the
input here this is a function s of X is
a function and the output for instance
sin of x - A is a function now you tell
me can you describe this function by
a finite dimen in general you can
approximate it very well with finite
dimensional objects but can you describe
them entirely by finite dimensional
objects no right because it's it's a
function so that's why it's an infinite
dimensional quantity you cannot describe
it in terms of just one or a vector of
finite dimensional quantities and the
output is also going to be infinite
dimensional because again it's a
function okay that's why it's a mapping
between functions and functions we don't
need to think in terms of images we can
just think in terms of analytical
expression
that it takes s of X it goes to sin of
xus 80 it can take um I don't know
exponential of Min - x and it goes to
exponential of x - 8 so it's a mapping
which takes any function and it maps to
any other function or a relevant
function okay you can take another
mapping 1 -
x^2 and then it goes to 1 - x - a²
something like this you see so it takes
functions and it turns out functions is
that clear to you now good so you can
always ask questions because then other
people who are afraid of asking or don't
want to ask they they also benefit from
that good so now let's go back to my to
my slide here so because we don't have
to go fast it's more important that you
learn the concepts so it's good that you
ask questions so this as I said is a
core of operator learning that you
really have to learn and this is you'll
see that it's not a huge difference but
a priority it's a big difference from
sort of what you have seen so far right
because what you've seen so far let's
say that you want to classify an image
an image is always given at least um in
terms of what we have in terms of stock
images let's say the Mist this is a
standard image classification data set
these are 32 by 32 images okay they
they're all 28 by 28 even I keep on
forgetting 28 by 28 images so the entire
image is described in terms of 784
pixels and that's it but here as I told
you also with this example I don't have
that kind of a description so for a
traditional sort of a CNN let's say or
any any machine learning task so what
you have is a 28x 28 image and the
output is going to be some classes right
so there are 10 classes and you churn
out the class probabilities so have a
784 dimensional input and you have a 10
dimensional output so it's a map
between let's say vectors and vectors
maybe of very high Dimensions but
vectors and vectors here in just
conceptually this is the difference
because now I cannot describe it I can
approximate it and we have to but I
cannot describe it in terms of just one
or 10 or 100 uh numbers right because
these are functions this is a function
this is a function this is a function so
intrinsically or implicitly I have to
work with infinite dimensional inputs
and infinite dimensional outputs and
this is a stock departure from what you
have seen before where the dnn's the
Deep neural networks these were mappings
from finite dimensional inputs to finite
dimensional outputs so there is a there
is an issue here there's a gulf here and
for the next several lectures we will
see how we bridge this gulf right so is
that clear so the difference in Paradigm
the difference in setup is quite Stark
okay but how do we we have to deal with
this somehow right means after all we do
make make use of these Frameworks so
what do we do so first option that I
give you is we cheat okay so actually
this is uh we
cheat don't get confused but there is at
least many many applications you can
actually cheat your way you don't have
to you don't have to solve this problem
but eventually in the next lecture you
will see that we have to get out of this
cheating we can't use this trick all the
time time and we have to essentially
solve the problems so the point is and
maybe I could have even given you an
introduction right here so what if my
input was
um let's say my in this particular
example the cheating is uh can be made
rather explicit that my input
distribution so remember that my input
functions un not were drawn from a
distribution me right what if I said
that instead of looking at all possible
functions which is uh unnecessary in
practice my inputs were given like this
so they were let's say summation of a k
sin K
pix okay summation of K AK sin K pix and
AK was uniformly distributed in minus1
1 okay and K went from 1 to
10 okay so in other words so this was my
my data set or the task itself is not to
look at arbitrary functions that is
going to I'll give you some concrete
examples it doesn't make any sense in
general but uh it is restricted to a
certain class of functions that my class
of functions is always given
by is always given by these class of
functions so in other words my input is
given by these set of
parameters so these are my parameters
and uh what what I can do is I can work
with these parameters so instead of an
operator learning problem I have a
finite dimensional problem because now
my inputs just by definition are
restricted to this class AK remember
because these are the coefficients of a
certain basis and the basis is fixed so
now my my input is going to be finite
dimensional right and my output is
potentially also finite dimensional I
can do that by simply taking AK
x and t and turning out my solution
which is going to be U of x a t a in
other words I can rewrite my solution in
terms of space time and some finite
dimensional inputs so this was 10
Dimensions this is one dimension one
dimension 12 dimensions and a map to
just one number so this is one dimension
so in other words by restricting the
space base of my data set by restricting
my tasks generality of course you will
see that you pay a price right but uh
let's let's do this cheating for the
time being what I have done is that
instead of having an infinite Dimensions
to infinite Dimensions nothing I have
managed to escape by just having
something which goes from 12 Dimension
to one dimension and this is what is
called parametric PDS so remember that
this was my setup this is the setup in
which I
work but the simplified setting that I
told you is that the data that I'm going
to draw that's why I had this
probability measure here this measure
has a finite dimensional
support or it can be described all the
data essentially this is a mathematical
way of saying a precise yes
James we to C resolution is that the
same thing you will see that okay there
is a there is a there's a connection
here but at the moment I'm not fixing
resolutions right I'm simply saying that
my data itself is not coming from a very
arbitrary class of functions but it's
only coming from a class of functions
that are given in terms of finitely many
parameters so the number of degrees of
freedom for my input is finite and
subsequently I can also make the number
of degrees of freedom for my output
finite that's why I said I'm cheating
here right because I'm sort of reducing
because all sence in some sense is a
reduction right you reduce what is
unknown to what is known we know how to
deal with finite dimensional inputs and
outputs so somehow you have to Project
Infinite dimensional inputs and outputs
into this finite dimensional setting
right and I'll give you a concrete
example where this this makes sense so
here so this is what is called a
parameterized PD because uh so for
instance in this particular example now
I'm running out of space here I guess
but what you could have done is you
could have looked at a that this would
be
UT plus okay I was okay let's say that
instead of a I would have had C here
probably because and this U
not depended not just on X but on some a
okay this is this summation of vector a
so this is this a k sin K
pix so in that case your initial data
it's this a parametric PD because it
depends the solution itself depends on
time on space and on the parameter a
this is this is the basic idea and here
is an example which is much more so I
call the parameter y sorry for the
confusion in notation uh so it's called
a parameter Y and this is finite
Dimension it belongs to Dy but Dy can be
large dimension of Dy can be large so
here is a concrete example for this to
just to illustrate this point so if you
want to design a new aircraft uh the
critical design element is what is
called designing the wi right because uh
aircraft is flown by the lift that is
generated by having an aerodynamic Wing
that generates a lot of lift and that
doesn't have a lot of drag so this is
the basic so you cannot have a car which
is going to fly but a plane flies
because it has this aerodynamic shape
among other things right so then so if
you design the wing so what people do is
uh in general to do anything in 3D is
hard so people take cross-sections of
the wing because if you have seen when
you have flown you have seen an aircraft
and you see that you can essentially
compose it of cross-sections there's not
a lot of variation within the shape of
the cross-section only the sort of the
dimensions the the length of the
cross-section so along each
cross-section you get what is called a
air foil okay so this object here is an
air for why is this not working
now okay air for so this is like think
of it as a 2d Wing right but it's of
course when you put it together you get
a proper Wing So now in general these
things have to be manufactur these
things have described uh and so what
people do is that they they have a
certain base reference aoil so black
here is a reference okay so this is
reference and then they of course you
start with a reference air foil which is
based on the engineers intuition but you
want to see whether you can increase the
lift or reduce the drag or increase the
lift to drag ratio and so on so what
they do is that they start with the
reference air foil so some srf and then
they generate some design space okay so
this is some finitely many parameter is
a from 1 to whatever Dy of y
* oh I have some concrete examples later
but perhaps it's easier to say that it's
Sy y so in other words you can see here
in this design what is called the design
envelope that uh this the Shaded regions
this represent a whole set of shapes
that are mapped by these parameters okay
so these parameters they are sometimes
called as hi na parameters in Dynamics
but the details are not important there
are something between 20 and 50
parameters so the entire air foil the
the the design is somehow restricted the
number of degrees of freedom are
restricted to these 50 parameters up to
50 usually people use 20 and then what
you do is that you compute the whole
flow field here so here as you can see
the the inputs are of course the space
coordinates because this is steady state
aerodynamics you don't care what happens
during takeoff and L in terms of fuel
efficiency but you care about what
happens during Cruise conditions so it's
X Y X and this is the Y is the shape
parameters so this is a concrete example
of what I just Illustrated the last time
around right and then the output is
simply the flow parameters the
velocities the density and so on so
these are functions for instance row of
x y and let's say the pressure p of XY
and so on and from these parameters you
can compute things like drag and lift
and so body forces which are just
observables okay so these the solution
itself is in the form of a field and
otherwise drag lift these are sort of
observables so what we do by this
cheating is essentially take an infinite
dimensional problem reduce it to finite
Dimensions simply by restricting the
input space and the output space so we
will in some form or the other we have
to do it uh in general but this is a
sort of brutal way of doing it right you
simply say that you look at Finly many
parameters but many many people think of
design engineering design as operating
within this space that you finite many
parameters and you're trying to find
Optimal values within those parameter
sets Okay how else can we design now
let's assume that this is our problem
that we have cheated we have projected
our problem down from infinite
Dimensions to finite Dimensions simply
by reducing the measure by reducing the
data set that um the diversity of the
data set that the dimension of the data
set that we have once we do that it's
just plain vanilla machine learn right
these are the things that you're already
familiar with because now remember that
my inputs are this X and Y also T if
it's a Time dependent be and then all
that you do is I I Club it together I
call it as a zed so this is txy these
are all the inputs this is time space
parameter and my solution is given by
some l l Of Z this could be the field it
could be an observable a quantity of
interest but it's a mapping between
finite dimensions and finite Dimensions
so you could just use your plain vanilla
deep neural networks means the usual
usual things you have these layers you
have uh the weights and vies I don't
have to tell you this you have some
activation function and now since we are
not going to differentiate uh like we
did with pins we can take any activation
function it could be relu for instance
which is the and widely used activation
function right and then how do we do how
do we have data the UNS that we have the
sort of the argument or the hypothesis
that we have for data usually is that
this data is randomly generated right so
this is this is hypothesis so what you
can think of is that now these things
think of them as parameters in space so
for instance within this um set of
shapes you will randomly generate let's
say thousand shapes you'll compute the
field with respect to a th shapes
thousand is just a number that I gave
you that would be quite expensive
because each of these computations will
be between one and two minutes me even
the fastest codes will not be will be of
the order of a minute and when I was a
PhD student or a master student like you
guys this was the order of two hours
maybe so we have done like at least two
orders of magnitude down uh so things
things have improved but it's still of
the order of a minute but if you
generate a th000 it's ,00 minutes which
is which is sometime right it's not
serious time so this is going to provide
you with the data so L of zi is your
data you can think of this as your
labels so zis are the points at which
the sampling is taking place there could
be some noise but I'm operating in a
noise free regime just for Simplicity
and then you look at the output of the
neural network which is given here these
are the
predictions and this is not um this is
regression problem essentially it's not
a classification problem so what you do
in this particular case is that you just
use whatever Sgt adom whatever to
minimize this loss function so the
algorithm itself is super simple you
have finitely many parameters you take a
random set of these parameters generate
some data and then you learn the
solution Operator by using standard deep
neuron Network explain van netw any
questions on this
no from people on Zoom no okay so this
is this is as as easy as it gets the the
question is is this going to work out
what are the what are the caveats do we
have do we have some issues let's see
what what happens right so the first
question always at least for a
mathematician is that is is this ever
going to work so in particular if you're
given some tolerance here so this is
some
tolerance the question is can we find a
deep neural network can we find a
suitable architecture and so on such
that for the underlying map you can
think of it as an operator now but it's
really a map because operator has been
reduced to a function can you find uh
deep new network such that these things
are close to each other and if you
remember the last lecture I had already
talked about it that we have this
Universal approximation property and
what does the universal approximation
property do it provides you the
guarantee that yes the always be even a
shallow neuron Network even a one layer
neuron Network such that this is true as
long as this map is continuous and in
fact um even less than continuous it
could be integrable it's as long as it's
measurable then indeed this can be done
okay so from the in principle this is
not a hard problem because it's finite
dimensional so you can always solve it
however the point is uh that there is a
there is a price that one has to pay
with respect to complexity so the size
of this neuron Network so let me say m
is a number of parameters then there are
some results which essentially say but
the rate at which this convergence
happens in general of course there are
there are problems where it is uh where
this is the worst case guarantee but in
general it scales with two things it
scales with the regularity of your map
so this s is the number of
derivatives so if you have a smooth
function s is uh large right it could be
10 100 whatever uh p is some integr
ility think of it as 1 and two and D Bar
here is the dimension so D Bar is the
dimension other words it's easier to
learn smooth Maps than things which are
complicated and it's easier to learn in
low Dimensions than in high Dimensions
this is sort of the sort of the thinking
that that happens and the point is that
in general this is not good because then
you are hit with a curse of
dimensionality that even in sort of low
Dimensions um you will end up with very
very large Network size so if you do the
math then already you get into a 100 um
no is it 100 billion or no a trillion
right 10 the 12 is a trillion and this
is even chat GPT the the underlying
model is not like that so there this
this does not explain anything right
because even with very very low
Dimensions you end up with very very
large numbers so there is a curse of
dimensionality which I had already
spoken about in the last lecture but it
turns out that that is not the case
because at the end of the day we are not
looking at some random mappings here
right these mappings or these functions
this L here this object this operators
if you want to think of it like that
these are much more structure in them
and the structure comes from the fact
that these are solutions of pdes so
Solutions of pdes could be smooth they
have other forms of regularity
dimensionality reduction and essentially
there are lots and lots of results
there's there's some detail here is not
important but there are lots and lots of
results which essentially tell you that
this error the early error which scal
like exponential in dimension it scales
much better than that for because of the
solutions of PDs so this is for all
kinds of PDs elliptic hyperbolic
parabolic and so on there lots of
results and this Sigma here which tells
you the rate this can be linear
quadratic even logarithmic for some PDS
okay so if something scales linear in
dimension it's not a big deal or
quadratically in dimension it's not such
a big deal so this is there is some
regularity or compressibility of the
data which tells us that at least in
terms of the approximation error the
error that we get from in principle
error of approximating this we can we
can do rather well right so this is this
is not such an issue however the main
point is that you also have other
sources of error I think Ben mentioned
them at the beginning of his lectures
you have optimization error this is our
familiar friend training error that we
saw a in the last couple of lectures and
there is some generalization eror and
this is the one that I'm going to Target
here because once you have random points
remember that my data was supposed to be
random once you have random points then
there is a limit to this and the limit
is given by also we saw in the last
lecture there essentially square root of
n okay morally square root of n even
though there is a logarithmic correction
here this always there because things
are things are correlated so essentially
at the end of the day we can say that my
overall error this behaves in the
following man and this is important
these considerations are important
because it depends on the network
somehow but let's say this this C is
some sometimes called in theoretical
machine learning as a compressibility
factor compressibility factor some
people also call it as Kappa but I I
just called it a c okay but essentially
the in terms of sample complexity
because this is for as an issue this is
always going like a square root it's
slightly worse than a square root even
in the the guarantee is slightly worse
than a square root but it is let's say a
square root and this is again a problem
for us because remember that even if
this was order of one let's say it's a
number one and I want an error of 1% so
1% is 1 over 100 right assuming that
everything is of the order of one so if
I need 1 over 100 so I have to find the
number of samples the square root is 100
and that is 10,000 so 10,000 is a lot of
lot of samples because uh just imagine
as I said a single simulation takes me
approximately 2 minutes 10,000 samples
will take me 20,000 minutes and this is
this is too much right in 2D so in 3D
you can imagine nothing runs in one
minute 3D a single output of the code
takes you anything from one hour on on a
small machine to hundreds or thousands
of hours or millions of hours on a
supercomputer so one has to be careful
and this is some some sense the big
challenge that I'm trying to sort of
pose here that uh we are dealing with an
object so this is not like taking an
image taking an image is cheap you know
compared to solving a PD or solving
differential equations or just
simulating physics so forget about the
low regularity here this is neither here
nor there but essentially we are in a
relatively and this is
relative because also if you're looking
at number of sick people like in medical
AI it's even less you know so so it's
one has to be relative relatively data
poor regime and this can be to some
extent at least opped in contrast to the
Big Data success of machine learning
that uh has come up from large data sets
right and towards the end of our course
I'll convince you that actually here
also we need large data sets but for the
timing let's pretend that we can never
get access to large data sets and we
have to work with relatively small data
sets perhaps the order of hundred of
hundreds of samples not tens of
thousands of samples right and how are
we going to leverage that and how are we
going to use that so there's no point in
me starting a new topic we will do that
in the next lecture okay so there's only
3 minutes left okay so have a nice
weekend and last next week uh remember
that Friday is Easter Friday Good Friday
so this this a holiday we have only one
lecture and there we will talk more
about operator learning and see whether
this cheating works so even cheating
doesn't work here because don't have
enough data right so and then what
happens when you don't cheat okay next
week then so long